a little bit sheepishly, actually, about this idea
that maybe we could use these patterns and shapes
to produce a wetsuit to try and mitigate the risk of shark attack,
and fortunately, he thought that was a good idea.
So what ensued is a collaborative bit of research
supported by the West Australian State Government.
And we did three key things.
The first is that we mapped the characteristics,
the physical characteristics of the eyes
of the three main predatory sharks,
so the great white, tiger and bull shark.
We did that genetically
and we did that anatomically.
The next thing we did was to understand,
using complex computer modeling,
what that eye can see
at different depths, distances,
light conditions, and water clarity in the ocean.
And from there, we were able to pinpoint
two key characteristics:
what patterns and shapes would present the wearer
as hidden or hard to make out in the water, cryptic,
and what patterns and shapes might provide
the greatest contrast but provide the greatest
breakup of profile
so that that person wasn't confused for shark prey
or shark food.
The next thing we needed to do was to convert this
into wetsuits that people might actually wear,
and to that end, I invited Ray Smith,
a surfer, industrial designer, wetsuit designer,
and in fact the guy that designed the original Quiksilver logo,
to come over and sit with the science team
and interpret that science
into aesthetic wetsuits that people might actually wear.
And here's an example of one of the first drawings.
So this is what I call a "don't eat me" wetsuit.
So this takes that banding idea,
takes that banding idea, it's highly visible,
provides a highly disruptive profile,
and is intended to prevent the shark
from considering that you would be ordinary food,
and potentially even create confusion for the shark.
And this one's configured to go with a surfboard.
You can see that dark, opaque panel on the front,
and it's particularly better for the surface,
where being backlit and providing a silhouette
is problematic.
Second iteration is the cryptic wetsuit,
or the one which attempts to hide the wearer
in the water column.
There are three panels on this suit,
and in any given conditions,
one or more of those panels
will match the reflective spectra of the water
so as to disappear fully or partially,
leaving the last panel or panels
to create a disruptive profile in the water column.
And this one's particularly well-suited
to the dive configuration,
so when you're deeper under the water.
So we knew that we had
some really solid science here.
We knew, if you wanted to stand out,
you needed to look stripy,
and we knew if you wanted to be cryptic,
you needed to look like this.
But the acid test is always going to be,
how would sharks really behave
in the context of these patterns and shapes.
And testing to simulate a person in a wetsuit
in the water with a predatory shark
in a natural environment
is actually a lot harder than you might think.
(Laughter)
So we have to bait the rig,
because we need to get the statistical number
of samples through to get the scientific evidence,
and by baiting the rig,
we're obviously changing shark behavior.
We can't put humans in the water.
We're ethically precluded from even using
humanoid shapes and baiting them up in the water.
But nevertheless, we started the testing process
in January of this year,
initially with tiger sharks
and subsequently with great white sharks.
The way we did that
was to get a perforated drum which is full of bait,
wrap it in a neoprene skin,
and then run two stereo underwater cameras
to watch how the shark actually engages with that rig.
And because we use stereo,
we can capture all the statistics on how big the shark is,
what angle it comes in at, how quickly it leaves,
and what its behavior is
in an empirical rather than a subjective way.
Because we needed to preserve the scientific method,
we ran a control rig
which was a black neoprene rig
just like a normal black wetsuit
against the, what we call,
SAMS technology rig.
And the results were not just exciting,
but very encouraging,
and today I would like to just give you a snapshot
of two of those engagements.
So here we've got a four-meter tiger shark
engaging the black control rig,
which it had encountered about
a minute and a half before.
Now that exact same shark had engaged,
or encountered this SAMS rig,
which is the Elude SAMS rig,
about eight minutes before,
and spent six minutes circling it, hunting for it,
looking for what it could smell and sense but not see,
and this was the final engagement.
Great white sharks are more confident than the tigers,
and here you see great white shark
engaging a control rig,
so a black neoprene wetsuit,
and going straight to the bottom,
coming up
and engaging.
In contrast to the SAMS technology rig,
this is the banded one,
where it's more tactile,
it's more investigative,
it's more apprehensive,
and shows a reluctance to come straight in and go.
(Applause)
So, it's important for us that all the testing is done independently,
and the University of W.A. is doing the testing.
It'll be an ongoing process.
It's subject to peer review and subject to publication.
It's so important that this concept
is led with the science.
From the perspective of Shark Attack Mitigation Systems,
we're a biotechnology licensing company,
so we don't make wetsuits ourselves.
We'll license others to do that.
But I thought you might be interested
in seeing what SAMS technology looks like
embedded in a wetsuit, and to that end,
for the first time, live, worldwide --
(Laughter) —
I can show you what biological adaptation,
science and design looks like in real life.
So I can welcome Sam, the surfer,
from this side. Where are you, Sam?
(Applause)
And Eduardo.
Cheers, mate.
Cheers.
Thanks, gentlemen. (Applause)
So what have we done here?
Well, to my mind, rather than take a blank sheet
and use science as a tool for invention,
we've paid attention to the biological evidence,
we've put importance to the
human anecdotal evidence,
and we've used science as a tool
for translation,
translation of something that was already there
into something that we can use for the benefit of mankind.
And it strikes me that this idea of science
as a tool for translation rather than invention
is one that we can apply much more widely than this
in the pursuit of innovation.
After all, did the Wright brothers
discover manned flight,
or did they observe the biological fact of flight
and translate that mechanically, replicate it
in a way that humans could use?
As for the humble wetsuit,
who knows what oceanwear will look like
in two years' time, in five years' time
or in 50 years' time, but with this new thinking,
I'm guessing there's a fair chance
it won't be pure black.
Thank you.
(Applause)